[Music]
Chantelle never thought she'd need
donated soap and toothpaste to keep her
daughters and her house clean but when
her job as cabin crew was grounded by
the pandemic furlough payments barely
covered her end and she had to choose
between buying food and basic hygiene
products I was trying to make things so
make cleaning products myself make
toothpaste myself baking soda and I've
got two children at the time they were
two and seven but um
it wasn't going very well the smell of
white vinegar as a cleaning product
wasn't something they enjoyed and baking
soda wasn't something
um they could tolerate you don't want to
admit that you failed and you you don't
want your children to know how bad
things are and things are as bad as that
for nine million people who can't afford
basic toiletries according to research
by charity in-kind direct a number that
tripled and last year they see with more
than a third of those in need living
with children we hear examples of of
families using washing up Liquid as
shampoo and shower gel children sharing
toothbrushes you know the the people
making their own period products by
going into Tescos and and using some of
the paper under in a carry bag
is isn't that feels like a pretty basic
human right that people should have
access to those things the food banks
provide the only access for those
struggling the most were volunteers say
it's the toiletries that people are now
queuing up for staff in this food bank
say they have always been busy but what
people are increasingly in desperate
need of are hygiene products things like
shower gels period pads and even just
washing up liquid
and there isn't enough to meet the
demand leading to some desperate
measures it was shocking to me when they
come to an organization like breadline
London and they're asking for period
products especially because they're
using newspaper they've got newspaper
that they've got ladies have got
newspaper that stacked up just in case
they can't have anything I'm like I just
I don't understand how I can not give
them but if that means that I can I have
to keep it from someone else it's just
so unreasonable it's just I just feel so
so sad
impossible choices that no one should be
making
Sky News